Rolanda Salinas joins us right now he is
the Democratic mayor of Eagle Pass Texas
right now he has issued an emergency
declaration as the migrant crisis
certainly builds in his neck of the
woods mayor very good to have you how
are things today
happy to be here good afternoon that
things are a bit chaotic to say the
least here in Eagle Pass Texas for it's
been like that the last couple days very
uh disappointing situation it's uh we're
trying to do our best here to maintain
the peace maintained order that's my
number one priority as a mayor of this
city this is a great City so I'm trying
to maintain the peace our economy local
economy has taken a hit what we're doing
the best we can all right now this
emergency declaration you're obviously
overwhelmed in just the last few days
what happened
and you have thousands of people coming
into uh the country through Piedras
negras which is the Mexican counterpart
into Eagle Pass and we just can't
sustain thousands of people coming in
we're a city of approximately 28
000 people to have that amount of people
roaming our streets it's just it's
unacceptable we have a limited resources
limited police force Fire EMS so it's
disappointing to see all these people
come in without a consequence that's
kind of what what gets me they're coming
in kind of like a come one come out kind
of situation and it's uh very
disheartening to see this happening
especially here in the city of Eagle
Pass do you reach out to anyone in
Washington to the White House the
homeland security for help
I've reached out to our Representatives
I've been in touch with our Congressman
Tony Gonzalez uh he's done very good
good things for right for Eagle Pass
I've been in touch with with the state
with DPS uh the governor's office they
have been helpful so he will pass by
sending in additional help we need all
the help we can get just to maintain
border and and maintain the peace here
in our city but it has taken a toll one
of the bad things that happened is that
CDP had to close one of our bridges we
have two International Bridges Bridge
one had to be closed and that'll that
not only messes with with uh the speed
with the peace and safety of the
community but also the economy you close
that bridge you're directly impacting
the economy of Eagle Pass and also the
state economy I mean we have thousands
of
Commerce
trucks that come in through Eagle Pass
in Mexico So you you're not only
affecting the safety but also the local
and state economy you know Homeland
Security secretary mayorka says there's
not a crisis going on the administration
does not seem particularly alarmed by
what's been happening how do you feel
about that
whoever says that there's not a crisis
going on is 100 uh
that's not true it is obvious I'm
telling you as a mayor of the city there
is a crisis What's Happening Here is not
normal that this shouldn't happen in any
city in the United States because we're
a nation of laws people should be able
to come here legally we're all for that
I'm sure everybody agrees but to have
thousands of people come in without
consequence that should not be allowed
in the United States and again I'm just
disappointed in the system
would you welcome a visit by the
president United States
um you know he's been to the Border but
he never ran across any migrant when he
was uh should he be there should he at
least show his face and show and you get
a chance to show him what's going on
what you're dealing with
absolutely I've been saying that for the
last two years but here at Eagle Pass we
feel abandoned we shouldn't have to be
dealing with this this is a federal
issue I should be having a deal with
economic development there's other good
things going on in Eagle Pass Texas
shouldn't have to be dealing with an
immigration crisis and it would be nice
and I have made that invitation to
President Biden our vice president
anyone from the administration please
come visit Eagle Pass at the very least
you know what's going on acknowledge the
situation put out a statement call me
call us let us know what you're doing to
deter and control the situation at the
very least somebody up there in the
White House needs to put out a statement
and giving us a plan a time of action I
haven't had that
so Republicans have been saying that the
president really wants these illegals in
the country they say that that that can
can be the only explanation for his
hands-off behavior what do you think of
that
what what
the president is thinking but it's
obvious that there's no consequence to
thousands of people coming into the
United States of America
it's disappointing that if we live in an
age where this is happening right now in
the border and here in Eagle Pass
because Eagle Pass is a great City I'm
very proud to be the mayor of the city
of Eagle Pass and
at the same time I'm disappointing
disappointment
that the government is splitting this
happen
all right will you speak your mind mayor
and you've got a lot on your plate we
appreciate you taking the time you just
did right now to explain all you've got
on your plate Rolanda Salinas is the
Eagle Pass Texas Mayor trying to deal
with a crisis that as he pointed out is
now out of control and then stay with us
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else